est-ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres
ce que je propose c'est qu'on voit en
quoi vous croyez vraiment et qu'on fasse
une interview croyance
alors attention est-ce que vous croyez
en Dieu oui est-ce que vous croyez au
diable
non est-ce que vous croyez que dans
l'avenir tout le monde sera habillé avec
des combinaisons argentées non bien sûr
si si
vous croyez au voyage dans le temps non
si le voyage dans le temps avait été
existé des voyageurs du futur seraient
déjà venus nous voir
juste est-ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres
c'est une certitude scientifique parce
que
est-ce que vous croyez qu'on peut se
réincarner dans un meuble par exemple
non
est-ce que vous croyez la colonisation
de Mars oui oui deux fois est-ce que
vous croyez à la force comme dans Star
Wars oui parce que en fait la force on a
un certain sens c'est la quintessence
donc jusqu'à parler tout à l'heure c'est
la force obscure noire est-ce que vous
croyez si ça se trouve que l'humanité
n'est que le rêve d'un chien non non
est-ce que vous croyez au fantômes
vampires loup-garou à toutes ces
conneries non ce sont des personnages de
la réalité fantastique ils sont faits
pour être admirés dans les romans en
fait mais pas mais il existe pas du tout
existence est-ce que vous croyez à
l'innocence de Michael Jackson
est-ce que vous croyez à une quatrième
dimension oui bah oui oui
d'ailleurs attention
est-ce que vous croyez aux chaussettes
blanches avec des mocassins
ça dépend quand elles sont portées mais
oui quand même
devrait être accessible à tous à part
pour la ville
strictement non et d'ailleurs il y a pas
d'avenir dans le clonage pour nous
vraiment pas parce que c'est une
illusion tous les tenants du clonage
nous nous en fait
c'était pas mal ça c'est une carte de
clown
c'est pas mal
donc elle clonage tu crois pas du tout
non seulement j'y crois pas mais je
trouve que c'est une illusion de dire il
existe en ce moment aux États-Unis par
exemple une société qui commercialise
des des animaux en les clonant et en
disant voilà c'est la reproduction de
votre de votre animal favori c'est tout
à fait faux parce que quand on prend par
exemple un chat qui avait une tâche au
bout de la queue elle se retrouve sur le
soleil gauche
un chat ou un chien peu importe mais en
tout cas en tout cas
dans le dans le codage de l'animal alors
que tous les caractères sont supposés à
être les mêmes il se trouve que des
processus aléatoires interviennent et
que l'animal n'est jamais le même donc
c'est déjà une imposition au départ
dernière question la plus importante
est-ce que vous croyez la météo
d'Évelyne Dhéliat
mais à la météo en faites pas tellement
parce que là aussi il y a des phénomènes
aléatoires et qui font que on n'est pas
capable encore aujourd'hui de prévoir
quoi que ce soit matériaux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu